So,
um,
the subject is,
is drank in in particular
drinking too much and,
uh,
want to make it very obvious point that,
that drink and drinking a for better
or for worse often for the ladder as
closely tied to,
uh,
the economy,
a political life culture,
a social life sociability of,
of France.
Um,
and that,
uh,
this is,
has always been the case
as a wine producing country
and a country that a in the
course of the,
over the centuries produced
lots of other alcohol as well.
So,
uh,
let's,
um,
let's get going on that here.
I've drawn on the work
of an old friend of mine,
Susanna Barrows,
who studied,
uh,
studied aspects of this and,
and,
uh,
lots of other people as well.
And in addition to some,
probably a firsthand experience,
uh,
not about drinking too much of course,
but about,
uh,
about living in,
in France.
Uh,
in 1934,
the president of the France quite
forgettable character called the Alabama,
uh,
said that,
wine,
um,
does not only confer health and vigor
vigor to those people who are drinking it,
it has soothing properties that both
ensure the rational equilibrium of the
organism and create a
predisposition to harmony among men.
In addition,
it can be in difficult times.
It can poor confidence and hope
into our hesitating hearts.
Uh,
one of course thinks of,
uh,
of Peyto increasing the rum ration.
Uh,
uh,
it felt done,
in 1916 and the regular rounds of,
uh,
of doing shots before you,
went over the trenches,
the hesitating hearts,
uh,
soon a,
a dead hearts.
Uh,
there has been in France
a very long time from,
uh,
from the,
from about the 1880s,
a raw really into the early nineties,
1990s,
uh,
a denial of the problem of drinking.
This is not only France,
Poland,
of course,
which has even a higher
a rate of alcoholism.
I spent a lot of time
in Poland these days.
And you know,
it's really kind of amazing.
Uh,
and in,
in Russia,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
but because of the,
the,
the identity,
the identity of France and its national
identity with products of quality,
with fine wines,
with fine Boldo,
with fine Burgundy,
uh,
this denial became,
became rather,
um,
uh,
easier.
And the,
and the people who drank too much,
uh,
we're not drinking Feinberg and he's,
and,
uh,
find Boldo no,
are they,
uh,
today,
in 1875,
I barrows discovered that's a [inaudible]
of EMC actor informed it's readers
that in our country,
other drunkenness is not unknown.
It is far from having a character as
repellent and isn't the forests as an
England and as in America.
Now,
one of the reasons why,
you know,
a dictionary consulted by,
so what he's doing of people over
the ages could throw out such a line.
It's because there's been a
close identification with,
with people who are drinking too much
in particularly the lower classes in,
um,
in Britain with drinking hard liquor,
a gin.
I mean that isn't,
you know,
Hogarth and,
and,
and the prince,
and not just not just
getting wasted on beer.
Um,
and the United States,
a as Louis flee from cell found out,
uh,
the drink of choice was bourbon,
and uh,
and various whiskeys as in,
uh,
as in Scotland.
So,
so wine seem to be,
you know,
seem to be,
be,
be okay.
Um,
and um,
in England where the temperance
movement closely tied to,
you know,
to,
to organized religion
was terribly important.
And in,
in the Scandinavian states and in Germany,
uh,
the temperance movement was a,
but a small,
a dyke had put up against the,
against the waves,
the hurricane,
like waves of,
of,
of drink.
Now
wine,
his always been,
you know,
produced in France,
uh,
for uh,
for centuries and centuries.
There is a wine called call nos.
Uh,
Cor,
Nas.
It's produced down here,
uh,
in all that,
um,
uh,
quite near their own.
It's a very dark,
uh,
coastal and uniform to say very,
very hardy red wine that has
to be sat down for a long time.
That one of the Roman poets,
uh,
discussed in some Romans Century,
BC century.
Um,
in that particular region,
people had to produce wine.
Most of it was bad wine in order to trade
the wine for something to eat because
the reach of that particular
region that called the Viva,
hey,
it doesn't matter.
Couldn't produce very much
at all because of the,
of the rocky soil.
And so they would trade
their rather bad wine,
uh,
for,
for lentils,
for example,
produced around loopy higher up.
It doesn't matter.
Well,
wine had always been I,
the details don't matter.
So wine,
it always been a produced,
but a wine was fairly expensive.
And so people as we'll see in a while,
uh,
began to,
drink to drink other things.
Um,
Boldo wines where we're well known in,
in England and,
and thus a,
you know,
in,
in Britain they refer to
red wine is a clarity.
Uh,
and the reason that burgundy wines,
we're not well known in
Britain is fairly easy.
Just look at a map.
Boldo a dangerous trips,
uh,
you know,
across the,
around the,
around France,
around Brittany.
Would end up a wines arriving in,
in,
in British ports where,
for example,
in Belgium,
uh,
when people,
you know,
people drink great wines
are very good wines,
they tend to drink a
burgundy's because of,
because of the way,
uh,
the,
the lay of the land,
uh,
the land works.
Um,
but what's,
what's interesting about and what we're,
what,
what fits right into what
we're talking about is,
you know,
where people drank because obviously
the role of the cafe is so fundamental,
uh,
in France,
economic,
a political,
social and cultural life.
There's just a,
I mean,
any aspect you think of,
of modern France,
particularly in the third republic
is closely tied to that institution.
Uh,
you know,
impressionist painting for example,
uh,
the role of cafe [inaudible] where you
could go and be entertained as you,
uh,
as you drank,
is,
uh,
is important in,
in impressionism or paintings of,
uh,
of,
of the coast of the Norman coast by
Moh Hizo and lots of other people,
you know,
drink is,
is it's totally,
you know,
prevalent and,
and,
uh,
you know,
the guy and all the other ones.
I mean,
there's just the,
uh,
the practice pupation
with absent for example,
which more about that in a while,
which is just guys,
Darren,
it's just been a made legal again
within the last couple of years.
Um,
Eh,
you know,
cafes or where deals did use to get
done and we're deals to get done.
Or if you're living in a large city,
uh,
in a city,
in a world of apartments,
people will tend to,
first time they will invite you,
will be to a cafe often not to their own,
uh,
their own home.
Um,
but just as at restaurants,
which I'll talk about it at the end,
if their time,
uh,
I mean,
cafes themselves are of
relatively in French history,
recent phenomenon,
even the word Cafe,
a cafe.
What does it,
what does cafe a cafe is coffee.
Uh,
and it is with the rival of,
of,
of a,
of coffees from,
uh,
the new world.
Uh,
that becomes the real rave,
the real hit of the 18th century.
And that the emergence in
Britain of the Coffee House,
uh,
where politics is done,
we use,
and I use today cafe to be a
generic place where one drinks,
but in fact in the period
that we're considering at
the end of the 19th century,
uh,
people were,
were clever enough to realize that and
aware of their surroundings enough to
know that under the cafes are where
they're wealthy people went on the big
boulevards of Paris or on the root
level of Public Kid Republique in,
in,
in Leone,
uh,
or,
in the fancy neighborhoods of almost
every large city and ordinary people went
to drink in places,
uh,
where,
they did not often serve cafe
because it was so expensive.
And if they did,
it was a fairly rare thing
cause cafe was expensive.
Drink as we'll see in a while,
cost absolutely nothing.
And,
and even the names.
And I just picked a few,
you know,
six or seven.
I,
nobody's responsible for this and maybe
the French people would like to think
about this,
but,
but uh,
uh,
just,
you know,
the,
the kind of described
where people go to drink,
uh,
it varies from region to region often.
But let me just go through this briefly.
A cafe.
Well,
I've already said that.
Um,
and wait,
how they change because the days
of the CPM machine are all gone.
The pinball machine and all that.
I mean,
it just changes my God.
Now there's,
you know,
Starbucks had ha,
I mean I have nothing against Starbucks.
Do I?
I don't know.
But I have arrived in
Paris now and you know,
that's it.
That's as much of a shock.
And Dare I say blow is the arrival of,
of,
of Mcdonald's,
you know,
uh,
in all those years ago.
But anyway,
a cabinet and a,
when you think of cabaret,
you think of,
you don't with the Cabernet and people
think of people dancing and who think of,
you know,
Berlin and an it twenties
or something like that.
But a cabaret was a place for
ordinary people went to drink.
That's what a category is,
is,
uh,
an sw ne is simply a
word for the same thing.
Uh,
but in the north of
France and the stomach,
Nate,
you wouldn't go to,
to,
uh,
you know,
Isiah,
you wouldn't go to my say and I,
you know,
asked for the local stymie Ne,
uh,
again,
get it sort of a rural
place that you would drink.
Uh,
and again,
I'm thinking of impressionist
paintings that you might've seen with,
with a role of people going up there.
And I'm Sunday,
uh,
both,
you know,
males,
uh,
unattached males looking
for unattached females and,
and families going out
and along the Marne,
which in the 1920s and thirties,
outside of Paris was a real,
real hot place to go.
Uh,
you know,
again,
get with very rural,
Rural Abou Shawl.
The word in French
Bouchard show means a cork.
Uh,
it also means a traffic
jam as a cork in a bottle,
as a traffic jam.
Nobody can get through cause it's
bushland or wine can be Boucher in a too,
but,
but anyway,
uh,
but,
Bouchama is a rural drinking place.
And when I think of Boucher,
I think of a place where,
uh,
you know,
you go with your friends and,
and,
uh,
maybe play a little boost,
you know,
a alongside of that and,
and it's,
it's identity,
you've leisure,
but seeking the,
you know,
seeking the outside of,
of,
uh,
um,
you know,
of the city,
uh,
to find some greenery,
on a,
uh,
on a Sunday.
And you know,
I think of lean all,
for example,
of all the uni at the
end of the 19th century,
going across the Rhone River,
uh,
to,
working class full book called Lucky ots.
And then going further out in
these places like Brooke Toe,
it doesn't matter,
but where,
where,
uh,
you know,
it was just full of places to drink,
uh,
or,
um,
uh,
Sean Sean put a w is,
is a form of a place of
male sociability women.
Uh,
I did not go there.
Usually it was sort of a
club where you're drinking a,
essentially tax free,
uh,
booze on the sly.
And it,
it's more,
it's identified particularly
with the department called the,
via a Var,
which is a,
you don't have to remember obviously that,
but it,
it,
uh,
which is so we don't,
we're too long isn't central pay.
Uh,
and they were important because in the
second republic that is 1848 to 1851,
this is one of the places where politics
sort of came to very ordinary people.
Um,
so,
uh,
but what'd you have as an
expansion of these places that,
that simply,
uh,
simply,
a phenomenal,
um,
and it,
uh,
it's hard to say.
I guess you'd probably is more accurate
to say that the expansion and the
production of wine,
uh,
helps generate the expansion of places
to drink along with the expansion of,
of the population,
uh,
itself.
Uh,
between 1840 and 1875,
uh,
the monitor wine produced
in France doubled.
Now this is the same time
as the population has,
is stagnating.
Um,
and in part this is because they're,
they're better roads and
there's railways to carry,
uh,
carry wine that's produced to,
um,
to a far off places,
but regions that hadn't traditionally
who'd produced much wine,
for example,
Columbia,
uh,
which Ann Rousse young way down here,
that is north of packing y'all around
parish renewal and the north of Pepin
y'all,
I begin producing lots
of wine and long doc,
uh,
that is,
this region down here becomes a massive
producer of wine that is around mobile
lea and,
and,
and all that.
So more and more wine,
more and more people are
dependent upon upon wine,
uh,
for,
for getting by.
Uh,
and as a matter of fact
that lots of people who,
who worked,
who work the fields during the
various harvest are paid in wine,
uh,
as part of their salary,
as opposed and have to take
those kinds of conditions.
And,
and then of course,
you can't carry a lot of wine with you.
So you ended up getting,
you know,
drinking a lot of it wherever you can.
Um,
and then of course,
what comes along,
and this is part of the,
these blows against the rural
economy in the third republic.
That helps also explain why the rural
population begins to deep populate.
Why rural France begins to depopulate.
Remember two thirds of the,
they fucked them all have
smaller populations in 1939
than they did an 1871 is
along comes the phylloxera disease here,
the philosopher disease,
which starts in the late 1870s.
And uh,
it comes after a another disease called,
it doesn't matter the name of the pay
buddying which attacks a silk worm
production.
So it just devastates,
it devastates particularly
this part of France.
But there isn't any place that produced
wine that isn't effected by the flux or,
uh,
and Louis Pasteur,
a name of what you've,
uh,
of whom you certainly you've
heard of Louis Pasteur.
I mean,
he does a lot of his work,
uh,
trying to study the origins of this wine
blight as well as the origins of this
silk worm blight,
uh,
that are these,
you know,
little began his little tosh,
their little spots on the silkworm.
And,
and,
uh,
flux.
There's basically a disease that,
you know,
that attacks the Seth at texts,
that kind of roots of,
of uh,
uh,
eh in the vineyards.
And ironically,
you know,
what,
what resolves the problem is
they restart a planning American,
uh,
um,
roots,
uh,
that plants that are
resistant to the flocks.
A,
and somebody told me recently
that California wine,
it's now facing flux.
Ra are,
I'm not,
I,
I had heard that,
I don't know much about the,
uh,
um,
a California wine.
But what this,
this is just absolutely devastates,
you know,
wine production,
uh,
in France.
And one of the results is that when
the wine crops begin to bounce back,
you know,
in the 1890s that many
places that produced wine
simply stopped producing wine
because it's not a long time.
You can't make any money on it.
Give you a couple of examples,
Brittany.
It's hard to imagine why and being
produced in Brittany outside of a very
ordinary wine called
Mooska day white wine,
right on the edge.
And so I've just got off of a reds,
uh,
also,
but,
but basically that all stops the
production of wine up in the north stops
wherever is possible with big
exception obviously of [inaudible],
uh,
here.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and other places.
The production of wine,
uh,
Eh,
you know,
is really cut back.
But this is a,
this is a big blow to the rural economy.
And lots of people abandoned their fields
or their converted to other things,
but wine bounces back.
And,
uh,
it takes its place again,
is one of the real dynamic
forces in modern French life.
But what's incredible is that the,
um,
you know,
the number of cafes continues
to expand exponentially.
And this suggests an obvious point is
that people drank more than just wine.
More about that in a minute.
Let's give you some suggestions,
some ideas and some figures.
1790,
Paris only had 4,000 cabaret,
4,000 cabaret in a,
in a town then of about 600,000 people,
more or less.
Um,
in 1830 places that had licenses to,
uh,
to serve alcohol in France.
Uh,
it was about 280,
2000 in France.
Now let me add one thing now,
having a license to sell alcohol.
Uh,
one of the things that really basically
no longer exists anymore but existed
until,
uh,
you know,
the 1960s,
uh,
was,
places you did other things,
but you could also buy a drink.
Well,
I mean,
I still,
I've been in grocery stores,
it's still our cafes or cafes that are
converted into grocery stores as well.
But,
um,
uh,
let me give you a ghoulish example.
Um,
I'll talk later about a,
or how they're sort of drawn about the
massacre there on the 10th of June,
1944 by the SS and where they simply
kill everybody in the village.
And when you go to this,
this sacred site,
a to see what's what they left standing,
which was everything you notice,
they're all these places
that were barbershops.
There were also part time drinking places.
You know,
I had a barber,
my Barbara in Paris.
I mean,
I don't go to the Barbara that much,
but he's got a buddy and
he was in the youth center,
the wheel.
And you had to get to him
early because if you a,
you know,
if you got there late,
he'd already got,
he already had pies,
six or seven or maybe
10 beers and you know,
you kind of look even
more damaged than I do.
I tried out Foxton once I said I made
a Honda [inaudible] eight 30 in the
morning because he starts at,
at uh,
at nine,
you and I got there and he,
and he was already a,
he'd been at that bar quite a long time.
A Bar that we call the annex because
that was for the annex of his shot.
But anyway,
when you see this horrible,
he ghoulish place,
uh,
peers of what happened there and they
left everything in the way it is.
You see these part time,
half grocery stores,
half,
uh,
drinking places,
half barbershops,
half drinking places.
A Boon.
Yeah,
I can remember,
you know,
in the Monterey,
the center part of the,
the right bank.
I can remember right down the street
from a place that we live for a long time
and not even that far from our apartment.
Uh,
the last,
uh,
boonies of the core quarter
and that you bought coal there,
coal and you bought drink there.
So these,
uh,
these,
these places that are licensed to sell,
drink,
uh,
you know,
cover all sorts of things.
They're not just your basic cafe with
the red sign there or whatever the big
flashing neon sign or the small ones,
you can barely read.
Uh,
uh,
but the,
the numbers in Cra,
incredible.
Okay.
1865,
this is not count places in Paris.
This is in France,
a country that's the size of Montana,
a little bigger,
um,
slightly more populated of course.
Um,
1830 there,
282,000 and France,
1865,
350,
1000,
1900,
435,000.
And then they,
uh,
they count Paris the first time,
the next year,
464,000,
1937,
half a million places to drink.
Uh,
and in 1953,
a mere 439,000.
Now,
um,
this represents for every man,
woman and child,
one bar for every 97 inhabitance,
one place to barge generic bar
for every 97 and a half minutes,
counting babies coning,
old ladies who could put them down
to maybe more about that in a minute.
Uh,
compared to one for 225 for Italy,
one for every 273 for Germany
and one forever 425 for England.
And also just his side.
You know,
I got to concentrate on
going ahead or I'll just,
every time I'd go off inside,
but,
but if you go to El Sauce,
uh,
you know,
you don't find cafes in the French sense,
they really serve more
like vine [inaudible] of
drinking places and they look
like German drinking places.
The more influenced by the,
by the culture there.
So this is a huge number of,
um,
uh,
of places to drink,
but it's also regionally specific.
Oh,
here's another good word for you.
Uh,
for those people that in France,
and I'm not trying to
exclude the others at all,
but it's just kinda fun to talk about.
Uh,
this is more of a,
Oh,
it's a Parisian,
but you know,
uh,
I'll go to my Zach to have a drink.
A Zach means zinc,
like,
like the,
the metal and,
and,
and because in a poor cabo,
hey,
rapport bar,
it's not copper or something like Lottie,
like that.
Uh,
those were things like the cafe amount
he can and this sort of sense of luxury
being associated in the 90s with the,
uh,
British and American world.
You know,
Mosiac is my,
you know,
sort of grungy bar where I
have my place at the bar,
uh,
which is,
you know,
depending on how long have you been,
there will be near where the Pattan,
where the woman who worked
in the cash register is.
We used to go to a place for ages.
In fact,
after I was married,
I was married here in a,
what's that place?
Uh,
Dwight Hall.
And then we went up,
we had the reception area
and then we went to France.
And the cafe that we'd
been going to fight,
I had been going to for a very long time,
close to cafes and a little reception
for us are right across from the national
archives.
And I'd been there so long that,
you know,
I moved up to moved up the ladder.
So,
so when I went in there,
you know,
my place was right next to the,
no,
I'm not saying I was
drinking a lot of stuff.
I mean I was just there,
you know,
for conversation,
you know me well enough already
to know that was the case and,
but,
but you know,
it,
it's,
there's this sort of hierarchy
there that it has to do with,
you know,
your association,
with that particular place.
And that was a very typical place.
And that the uh,
the,
the couple were from Oh,
van.
Yeah,
that is in,
in central France.
Uh,
born in misery.
That means they have 13
children I've mentioned before,
once and 12 and the other case.
And they had got the money together
because they had a neighbor who had no
children,
that loaned them the money to get on the
kind of equivalent of the web in those
days.
And to buy a cafe from another person
from o Vannia and then they worked there,
you know,
everyday from,
from five in the morning
until nine at night.
And now they're gone.
It's her,
she can ridiculous place.
But,
uh,
you know,
there were these places,
these Zach were ones that you had and
you never went to the one across the
street.
Never,
never.
I would go to another place,
uh,
in the Monterey and I used to start,
I started going there cause
because [inaudible] went
there and cause Trotsky had
been there and it's called
laptop teen and it's still there.
And that's a very different
one because all the,
uh,
is it now,
it's also become very chic,
very Bougie,
very ridiculous.
And,
and with the Bush dollar unaffordable
for almost anyone anyway.
Um,
so,
but it's regionally specific in the na,
which you already know about.
There was one bar for
every 46 inhabitance.
I mean,
that's amazing.
Um,
and you compare that to a elbows,
which is a town in Normandy,
one for every 60 Biz Yay way
down in the south of France,
uh,
which had a lower
alcoholism rate by the way.
A Bez Yay.
There was one for every 120 people.
So it tends to be very specific.
Uh,
but again,
this is babies too.
And of course everybody's heard those
horror stories about young mothers in the
1950s,
in the 1930s and the 1890s.
You know,
their babies crying all the time
where you get a little bit gay,
but yet,
well,
a piece of bread and dip
it in some brandy and,
and the stuff that Brad
in the baby's mouth and,
and uh,
uh,
there's a,
a smiling happy baby
and they get some sleep.
Is that disastrous or what
is absolutely terrible.
And they have to have these huge
campaigns against all of this.
But,
uh,
but basically babies didn't drink,
older people,
uh,
did for sure.
You know,
there's this woman that
used to come into the,
uh,
even the terms of what they would drink.
You'd go down in the morning,
I have my coffee before I go to the work
in the archives and really a coffee,
nothing else.
And there'd be this as this rather
elderly lady in there in May,
may come on the Alfonsi and she would
be tossing down [inaudible] stack,
which is a little glass of white wine.
And she would call the drink her Gloria.
Now that's mocking the
church cause the glory.
You know what you're seeing in the,
of what other people
were singing in the mass,
I guess at Gloria in Excelsis Day or
whatever they sang and she would have her,
Gloria was right there at her,
Zack and that she'd knock a
couple of those babies down and,
and you know,
go off a little shopping bag,
maybe lurching and trying to
avoid the 68 buses at roars by,
and she was out of there.
But,
but you know,
and so you,
but you,
you know,
it's just,
I mean,
it's also,
I,
again,
I said,
you know,
I'm making fun of this a little bit,
but it's sad because you'd see
all these people just blot,
or there was a guy at a bar called John.
He was a bit kind of
marginal guy and you know,
he disappeared.
And so people in the bar,
I wasn't there that was down
and working in another place.
But,
you know,
people went out and tried
to find him and end up,
cause he was,
uh,
you know,
he was on the spree,
uh,
you know,
as you said,
that's a term that comes from Berlin.
Uh,
I guess when soldiers would get all drunk
up during the occupation and they'd go
on a spree,
which was the river and get
off and drink way too much,
uh,
of these,
of these spirits.
So,
um,
how,
how much did people drink?
I mean,
it's scary.
it's just scary.
Um,
if,
um,
the consumption of wine per person,
per baby,
per old lady,
per you,
per everybody,
but I hope not per you was
in 1791 61 liters per year.
By 1850.
It was 75 liters per year.
By 1895 it was 113 liters per year.
But that's only wine.
Now.
Also when people drank at work,
we have a,
we have a native former neighbor who
was an alcoholic who stopped drinking.
He's also moved away.
He's a great,
he's a wonderful guy.
He worked at ODF,
which is a big gas factory and
electrical factory and Leon,
and he would drink six
or seven liters a day,
a day cause it was so hot where he worked.
Uh,
and you see the difference between
American and construction industry and,
and,
and fragile construction industry as,
as you know,
I mean,
sometimes you go there,
they're saying,
you know,
they're,
they're out directing traffic,
you know,
and they got a bottle in their hand.
Is there,
there's the directing you along there.
I mean,
it was part,
unfortunately,
of the culture of,
of daily,
um,
uh,
a daily existence.
Now that's just wine.
Then you have to add these other things.
And the other things,
the numbers are just phenomenal.
Um,
if you add distilled,
um,
uh,
it's still liquor per capita
consumption of pure alcohol,
in other words,
all distilled and fortified liquors,
50 proof and above.
Uh,
it was the average was 1.2,
uh,
leaders,
a year.
That's again counting every
old person and every baby.
Um,
and an 1880,
that doubled to 2.24 and by 1,890,
it was 4.35 liters.
So that's plus all the
wine on the average.
And what about beer?
Now Beer,
uh,
was not drunk in France until quite late.
I again,
you then,
here we go,
back to myth,
but the myth is that it came back
with was soldiers of Napoleon's armies
returning from the German states just as
the myth that the consumption of vodka,
which is very,
now there's a big problem because
they tell these companies,
sell this pernicious with vodka
stuff mixed with fruit juice.
You know,
and then in a,
in,
in the these days,
students get to get wasted with it.
But the,
but the taste for,
uh,
[inaudible] but the,
the,
uh,
the tea tastes for a,
for vodka was supposedly came to Monaca
with the first Russian restaurant opened
up by occupying soldiers in 18,
15.
But the big problem among,
among,
well among other problems,
but one of the big promise is absence,
absence.
And that's,
that's worth retaining ab Santas made for,
from wormwood.
It used to,
it was a Beta legal,
it's physiologically addictive.
It is addictive.
Drinking's addictive too.
But this is physiologically addictive.
It's bad stuff.
And they banned it in
1915 because of the war.
Um,
and I had some absence.
We have friends and Bezanson
who don't drink very much,
but they had some absinthe.
And of course I was willing
to take a shot at that and,
and uh,
and drink that,
and then it became legal again.
And,
and,
uh,
um,
now you can produce it,
uh,
and you can drink it.
And it's a,
it's more of a southern drink.
It's rather like,
no,
that's what [inaudible] said.
Tastes are like pasties,
pasties,
uh,
as trustees,
you know,
a sort of licorice tasting
and you mix of water with it.
Uh,
hopefully lots of water and
little pasties and you know,
people in the south and in,
in Corsica and Maasais and Volo,
Zuken all dash,
uh,
you know,
they're playing boule on
Sunday or something like that.
It's up until when they locked at the,
you know,
a couple of pasties and,
and uh,
um,
you know,
it's not very good for you.
It actually damages your brain
cells and rather major way.
You might have noticed.
I don't know.
But anyway,
I,
no,
I don't,
I don't drink,
I don't drink very much pesticides at all.
Uh,
but,
um,
but absence became one of the,
you know,
the focuses of,
of even some of the
impressionist paintings of cafe,
uh,
of cafe life.
I think it's Degas who has the absence
drinker a where you see a woman sitting
next to a man and you don't
know their relationship.
They're anonymous in the cafe.
You've kind of figured it out.
And in this painting,
which I should have brought in,
but I forgot,
uh,
to God,
brings you into it by not having
any price at any table leg.
And so you wonder
where's the table league?
And then you reach the glass and you
see the glass and it's simply called
absinthe and is always on
the cover of Emile Zola us,
which we'll come to now.
Uh,
immune so allows less,
some wow.
Inevitably in,
in,
uh,
in the,
in the translation,
um,
Zola realized among
others that France was,
seemed to be drinking himself to death.
And this came at a time
when there was fear.
I bought the French population,
which I've already said,
uh,
that the French population
is not reproducing itself.
And so they're,
they're afraid of that and less time.
Why,
uh,
briefly is the story about the decline
of the fall less someone who really,
you can't even translate it.
It's not never translated,
uh,
left somewhere would
mean I had got to be us.
So may,
it would be just completely get wiped out.
But also,
uh,
if you went to a place,
a bar every day instead
of coming to class,
uh,
you know,
that the place that you went,
that,
that caused your ruin,
uh,
would be the place of your fall sort of.
So it's got,
but anyway,
it just translate as the dive that was
a bad translation once somebody did or
just,
uh,
the bar or less time wise
or were things going wrong.
And it's a story about a woman
calls you have this and um,
and her,
uh,
her family and quotes
and as part of his long,
a long series of novels and,
and uh,
uh,
they all basically drinking
themselves to death.
And when she dies in a bed
of Straw at the end of the,
of the novel,
when one of the amazing scenes and,
and,
and the doctors are looking at,
at,
at her partner who's just
completely a raving alcoholic,
uh,
you know,
it,
it touched,
it touched many,
many people.
And the upper classes were,
were say,
well,
there they go again.
You know,
they're drinking cause they're the
drunken commoner a while they were putting
away their apoe and Fmol
by the ways that you know,
a drink or two or three
that people would have,
uh,
before a dinner.
And so a lot of published this in 1877
and what it was according to Barrows and
other people,
uh,
it was a call,
a cry of alarm for parliament
to do something about that.
Uh,
he,
he was a man of the left.
He defended Dreyfus against the
church and against the army.
And uh,
uh,
and all of that as you know,
but,
but it was a,
it was a non political,
it was a political statement.
He just wants somebody to do something
about the fact that the French seem to be
drinking themselves to death.
And if you didn't believe that all
you had to do was to go up to him,
Omar,
oh,
as today.
And see all the people,
all and a lot of them are,
are sort of sad sacks who had
terrible things happen to them.
But,
but the,
the problem is just
simply absolutely amazing.
Now that this book lesson,
wow,
there were 38 printings
of the book in one year,
uh,
after that year with publication again,
1877 and by 1882,
uh,
over 100,000 copies had been,
been sold.
Gimme given the example
that Barrow is also,
uh,
um,
found interesting,
of the influence of the book even
in the way w the way that the first
psychologists are the first sociologist,
the first anthropologist
described crowd behavior.
There was a guy called Gustaf
who wrote a book Lube Oil.
He Bon,
who wrote a book called the crowd.
And because know France was the France
of revolution and strikes the cause veal
and these other places,
these other scenes that
you know about from,
uh,
your me now,
he was interested in the
way that crowds behaved.
And he described them in ways that
reflected three of the kind of cultural,
intellectual preoccupations
of the period of the,
of the third republic
before World War One.
First,
he describes crowds as flighty,
that they'll go from one place to another.
Think of the women,
the castration scene,
you know,
in the indycars veal.
Uh,
and that was the,
that was her fucking by the fact that
women were supposed to be flighty and not
rational.
And what does that fear reflect or
fears reflective feminism of people like
Michelle hole and of women putting four
claims for the right to vote and for
other things as well.
Secondly,
crowds were,
we're supposed to be able
to be manipulated by people
on a big white horse like
Foodland,
shame that crowds didn't
have minds of their own,
but the rationality would sort
of be sucked out of them by,
by the moment.
And what does this reflect
reflects the first,
you know,
interest in hypnosis if Sharko
when we've read about and,
and,
and chips our wines,
a book,
charcoal chr cot,
whom Freud went to visit a,
to pay homage to when he went to Paris
and serve crowds were supposed to lurch
like drunks and the image of the drunk
and commoner this or upperclass view that
the commune was the work of the people
who had nothing to eat but found plenty
to drink in Paris.
In the cove of other
peoples' fancy apartments,
that the drunk and commoner was capable
of inflicting the same kind of harm and
the upper classes,
uh,
as had been the case,
or in many cases,
the imagine cases,
uh,
in previous,
revolutions.
And so,
um,
the impact of drink itself
can be seen in the origins of,
of crowd psychology.
I mean,
I've a very primitive of nature,
uh,
at,
you know,
it Cetera,
et cetera.
And in the novel,
which you've not read,
they read it in the other,
the first half of this course,
but,
uh,
he puts the focus,
focuses the novel on a street called,
which I will write on the board.
It's still there.
Um,
the Hulu,
the La glute
dog,
and he picks this,
the golden kind of taste.
Uh,
he picks us because it was a,
it's on the,
it was on the edge of parrots.
It's near the station of the north,
the Gal dinner.
And they had produced wine
there at one time of fine wine.
That was awful fine,
you know,
in quotes that was offered to the king,
uh,
once a year.
But it was a,
it was a street that was very
identified with a very ordinary people,
uh,
with workers in the big new industries,
but also these old artisans and Javez
you start your own laundry and then
everything just goes wrong.
It could possibly go wrong in her life
and they all get wasted together and
basically they all die.
Uh,
but,
but this was that,
this image of this street was something
that fascinated upper class readers.
And in fact,
it's only about 15 years ago that during
one of the elections that the Jacka
show huck,
uh,
went to that same street,
which is now identified with immigrant
populations and still has the same sort
of lightening rod effect on the upper
classes and said something like,
God,
it really smells here.
You know,
and just,
it was just,
it was almost like I'm gonna
Sarcozi referred to the Rock Chi,
the people in the suburbs as scum,
uh,
you know,
two years ago.
And so these are still sort of,
these images are very powerful.
And Zola and Zola knew what he was doing
and this was the effect that he wanted
to,
uh,
wanted to,
um,
uh,
make.
And we know what these people drag and
you can follow it if you read the last
time.
Wow.
They said,
you know,
a great paper topic,
I'm going to drink almost
everything they could.
Uh,
but in addition to UB,
Sam,
uh,
you know,
the regional production of fortified
Eau de vie of both of the [inaudible],
which are,
which are sweet and Oh,
divvy,
which is was it,
which is,
you know,
fairly sweet,
which is an extremely powerful,
it's like a brandy a,
if you look at a map of
alcoholism in France today,
um,
very the same thing really since
the middle of the 19th century.
Since you first have statistics
really from the 1870 [inaudible],
the big regions of alcoholism
are not in wine producing areas.
Now here again,
you can say,
the wine producers say,
yeah,
we have that healthy drink baby.
You know,
don't get us confused with these
heavy drinkers in those other places,
which is complete nonsense as you know.
But basically the,
the big alcohol rate is there.
It's in Paris,
and it's,
it's immediate surrounding.
It's in the north,
which is a,
and the Patek la,
because of all the economic
disadvantage in those regions.
These are not wine producing areas at all.
And in Brittany,
above all in Feeney stair,
which is the,
uh,
the most western,
department,
uh,
in France,
and they're not drinking wine there.
What are they drinking?
They're drinking a brandy,
apple brandy,
uh,
in,
in that case,
kind of a dose is the name of a day.
Pop them all in France,
Calvin dose,
the capitalists call ca n there
by you or by your tapestry.
Uh,
and of Dovii got off the
place and all this stuff,
uh,
there,
but kind of a dose,
uh,
became named after that.
They pop them all.
Uh,
and it is basically apple brandy.
There's old Calvados,
which is extremely good and extremely,
uh,
extremely good and good and very,
very expensive.
But there's this,
you're kind of Rotgut Calvados also.
Uh,
and,
but it's not just that,
it's that particular fruit.
I mean,
there's almost,
if you think of our sauce,
um,
you know,
there you have this pair
drink a called [inaudible],
which just means pair and French.
Um,
and it's,
it's,
it's Oda v that's made out of pair.
And you also have OTV that's
made out of raspberries,
is OTV that's made out of strawberries.
There's OTV that's made out of prunes.
Uh,
there's OTV that's made out
of almost any kind of fruit.
You can imagine how to Kiwi on,
on anything.
And everybody in France still
has the right to produce,
I guess it's about half a bathtub
full a year of that untaxed uh,
at,
um,
you know,
I know no expense.
And,
and,
and of course now in more refined times,
is that true or not?
I mean,
who knows?
But the idea that the,
and more about this in a minute,
uh,
that,
those kinds of alcohols or what you
would drink after dinner as you know,
digestives um,
you know,
but that's not what they were
doing at the time of Zoloft.
And that's not what they were doing.
And in the 1930s in the 1940s and leave,
and that's not what they're doing.
Uh,
in the 1960s in 1970s
in all sorts of places.
Uh,
you go to,
um,
you know,
go Sunday morning,
Sunday morning,
well,
women were in church,
the men were out getting,
getting totaled,
uh,
knocking down the,
the,
this stuff.
And not all the women went to church,
but,
but all of this,
uh,
Eh,
you know,
it tells you two things.
I mean,
if they're drinking,
well obviously way,
way,
way too much,
but an unbelievable amount of,
of alcohol,
which cuts back on life expense,
CIF,
uh,
to be sure,
but also that these,
all of this,
these alcoholics become part of
regional identities in France.
Uh,
that,
uh,
the,
I mean,
champagne is the classic example.
champagne is still,
uh,
obviously the fanciest drink that's
ordered for big for big occasions and
Champagne,
uh,
is extremely,
expensive.
There are other equivalents that are less
expensive that are produced in places
like Dee Dee Dee or there's a,
you know,
they're all over the places,
uh,
produced in Alsace infor,
but champagne,
uh,
hear it,
you know,
champagne is,
is basically this region here.
And that becomes not only a part
of the identity of Shump Pinea,
which is a region,
but with French national identity.
Uh,
and there's a book on that,
on how that happened,
how champagne,
uh,
becomes to be,
you know,
seen as,
as a,
um,
as a drink that you really celebrate for,
for big birthdays.
We have a friend who just hit 80,
and,
you know,
we left him before we went.
We left them a bottle of really good
champagne because that's something they
couldn't possibly afford.
Uh,
Eh,
you know,
and,
and the symbolism is,
is really there,
but I mean,
Boldo Boldo wines,
uh,
profit enormously from,
I think it's 1855 or [inaudible] 57.
I don't remember where they,
they,
they classify them according to
the great wines and the course.
Now a bottle of,
uh,
a shuttle,
a pet close or something like that,
uh,
which is,
the most famous Boldo along
with shut Toby cam would,
would go for a,
you know,
up to a,
$1,000.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
it's just incredible.
I mean,
those big kind of,
uh,
of a,
of a bull Dhalla,
we took as a presence,
somebody,
a Volvo that's now a $500 for,
you know,
the bottle because we bought
it about 15 years ago.
And these prices,
you know,
they hold their own,
but for all of the corruption,
for all of the trafficking too,
that,
you know,
it has gone on in Boldo,
uh,
Bergen eats the same thing.
I mean,
how closely the production of Burgundy
wines like vote Norma nae and,
you know,
Shiva Shamba and,
and,
uh,
you know,
the,
the really,
you know,
the great ones that I've ever could never
possibly afford to taste even like a
rich book.
I mean how those are identified with,
uh,
with the region,
is still a very important,
and another drink came along
to this identified with
the region that some of you
may know about.
And I hope if you're under 21,
you'll never drunk.
Uh,
and that is called a care.
K I r and you look at
the cane and you think,
well that's an Alsatian or Breton name.
Cause there aren't words in
French that begin with Kay.
But actually here was,
um,
he was the mayor of,
of digital,
uh,
I guess in about the forties or 50s,
1940s and 50s.
And he came up the idea of putting
somebody else who had the idea,
but he drank a lot of these things
and putting the sort of black currant,
uh,
into white wine.
And so then the key becomes part of
the regional identity of a burgundy.
I remember,
uh,
you know,
I was about your age,
see these great big posters saying,
you know,
have some sort of imagined
br Burgundian person,
uh,
proud of being a Burgundian
and he's tossing down a cure.
But all this fits together to create
this almost the impossibility of doing
anything about the big,
um,
a big problem of drinking.
And when Pyramind is frost,
who we'll meet later when he
tries to run for president,
he was the greatest
politician who never ha heal.
Uh,
you know,
we've never,
president of France and a great,
great man.
He,
he tried to,
uh,
start a drink milk campaign,
in 1954 and he was a
toast or French toast,
if you will,
because,
because they absolutely,
uh,
you know,
they just destroyed them.
The wine lobby just destroyed them.
They just went,
I asked for him and you could still,
I remember when he was drunk and,
uh,
guys would park their big trucks on hills
and not put the brake on and they'd go
and they'd come back,
uh,
you know,
after you know,
about 10 drinks and these things would
crash out of control and kill a bunch of
people.
Uh,
uh,
again,
even 10 years ago,
they started this campaign
against drinking too much.
Uh,
I must say now,
the last 10,
last five or six years,
they really have made it harder because
they have that going on the Swedish way.
But to have you used to be,
you could,
you could have an Aperitif,
uh,
you could have three
glasses of a big bite on,
but almost a big glass of
wine and maybe a little,
a cal vie afterward.
And the guy says,
you know,
blow into this,
uh,
this,
what do you call those,
those balloons?
Uh,
and he says,
well,
see Ya,
you know,
how these,
how does he put up over him?
And that's not the case anymore.
And that's really hurt rural restaurants.
Uh,
we had a guy in our village,
we had a restaurant in the summer
and he had this little teeny waiter,
this guy who was tiny,
tiny little guy.
And at the end of his job,
he had one beer and he went
out on the road and Bam,
you know,
he'd go there,
he turned the corner and
there's all these guys,
a big orange jackets and
all these lights and say,
sue famous here.
Blow on it,
a little balloon and he,
you know,
he had to pay it,
pay fine.
He couldn't afford it and
he wasn't drunk at all,
but he was very,
very thin guy and it was that
kind of account and went to a,
why am I telling you straight?
But they're interesting.
I went to a,
you know,
a,
a place of people we know a race pretty,
pretty good.
Why it produced pretty good wine.
So I went there with this guy,
his friend of mine who
makes me look like a,
it looks like a dwarf and I mean
you guys about probably about,
uh,
all 280 or 90 pounds,
a very big guy.
And he brought his friend from work,
ironically in a halfway
house for alcoholics.
Uh,
and this guy made my friend,
you know,
looked like a scat back,
looked like his title,
a guy.
And this guy is at least above.
I'm serious about three
or 50 pounds and you know,
he is as our village,
so I'm not driving anywhere.
Uh,
we're just going to go home and,
uh,
you know,
I can go back to reading my book,
you know.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
so he,
this guy he got,
he,
uh,
he hits the road,
he lives,
he lives about an hour and a half
away and he got controlled twice,
twice to blow the bloom.
No problem.
See Ya.
That's because the guy who weighs about
literally about 380 pounds and it's out
of there,
but they've done a very good thing,
uh,
in trying to,
you know,
in,
in trying to control a drink.
And the problem is that you see,
it used to be when you started out as
we leaving the stuff that we're not
leaving this subject.
Um,
uh,
used to be,
you know,
when our kids were going up
and Francis the same thing,
even when they were
two or three years old,
if you know them,
you can ask them,
but you'd put a,
you go to someone's house and they put
a little symbolic drop and they would
never drink it.
But it's a sense of participation.
And then when they got to be 12 or 13,
they put a little bit in champagne there
if they wanted to drink and they can
drink it.
But they grew up with it.
And then,
and then it wasn't like in high school,
you know,
when we first discovered
that stuff and you know,
then you just,
you know,
chugging it down and he sees
people staggering around
vomiting their lungs out.
And part of I really truly think is,
is that because it was so part of the
culture for both good and for bad,
and I emphasize the bad,
but it was a sense of participation
and that's what came to this sort of
elaboration of meals and
occasions for social ability.
That's where it becomes
part of the culture.
I mean,
the whole idea of,
you know,
a meal where you,
uh,
how are we doing here?
We got a,
we got a role,
um,
uh,
a meal where we have to,
you know,
where you start out with a little
something to drink and then you have white
wine with fish course or with
oysters or something like that.
And you have certain kinds of red wine
with the doc or whatever and then a
little red wine with cheese.
But you can also have white run with,
with goat's cheese and maybe a little,
you know,
Devi at the end of it.
This is something that's recent.
Most people couldn't ever
afford it eat like that.
They did cost cruet,
they ate whatever they could.
Uh,
they couldn't afford to have wine.
But this is something that comes out
of the evolution of restaurant culture.
The first restaurants were created
a really good book by Rebecca Spawn,
a about the origins of the restaurant.
Um,
we're,
we're creating the 18th century basically.
Cause remember the chef's
worked for the nobles,
uh,
and you'd have bullion,
which is supposed to make
you better if you were six,
you go to a place to have bullion and
then the chefs are all out of work.
This is a long version,
short version of a long subject and
they start setting up restaurants.
But it's really only in the late 19th
century that that the elaboration of meals
and,
and Michelin grading meals and grading,
you know,
what is a good restaurant
that's first 1900 diminish law.
They don't,
they're not grading yet.
They're simply saying to people on
the road and Michella makes tire.
So there they're the first
ones to say we have to have,
you have to have signs on roads saying
how far it is to get the yellow zone or
whatever.
Um,
and so this is part of this elaboration
that identify that keeps food and drink
in,
you know,
people's assessment of the French and
the French have their assessment of them
selves and regional identity.
Has Purdue extended disappearing
more about that in a tirade sometime.
Uh,
but not now because we're out of time.
But one can even argue that if rather
mission law with its regional guides and
with the guides to restaurant and grey
mule and the other guides have not kept
alive in some useful way,
a sense of what that one is
from one region as opposed
from to another and where
you eat certain things in one region that
you don't find specialties in another.
And where we all started that you drink
certain kinds of wine in some regions
and not others.
But above all that you not drink too much.
I'll pick up that theme again when we
get to the bed they poke cause I might be
able to resist it.